[Applause]
right no we just met I just love reading
to people meeting each other don't you
like to hug pillows how did you hold me
there like if she reaches for your
pillow just let her have that I have
short legs I'm short and I have to have
a pillow back here so my feet can touch
the baby yes that's what my feet on the
voice chair are dangling my legs are
like numb by the end of the show because
they don't reach the floor thank you
probably there's a problem I'm good you
guys can have all my pet okay hey we
were just talking actually in the break
this is random but I didn't know that
she was such like a superhero film like
guru I am too like I love him do you
love them like in games did you watch
that superhero oh my god I'm obsessed
with it I'm the biggest superhero fan
I'm like Robert Downey jr. is like my
all-time that's what started we were
talking about doctor Doolittle she's
coming up and that and I was like oh I
love Arbor Day and yeah we were both
talking about Karl I can't talk no
you're good I can't either
I'll do that like seven times no I I'm
like the biggest fan of him and I got to
host the Teen Choice Awards a couple of
months back yeah I don't know how that
happened either
it's all very happening because you're
likable people I got I got to like where
all the trailers were or whatever to get
ready for the show and my trailer was
right across from Robert Downey jr. and
I see him walking up and I can I stand
up yes no and I and he's like he's like
coming down this way and I'm coming out
of the trailer and I go up to him I go
and he's so sweet he goes he goes who
are you telling me everything and I go I
have nothing to say to you I am just I'm
just the biggest fan of you and this and
I just went I'll see you later and I
went back into the trailer and just got
back in other news like just terrified
and and then and then later like about
that Iron Man yeah and he's so he's so
sweet it's real and then really
yeah don't you hate when they're not
nice yeah he's exactly what and he's our
man in real life too like he's it's not
even a movie he's actually Tony Stark
and then if he actually had some flying
robots we need to be for Agnetha - but
then 30 minutes later then I'm coming
out to host the the Teen Choice Awards
and I see him sitting like right on the
side like in like in the audience or
whatever and I'm just I cannot imagine
what he is thinking like seeing me host
the show when I couldn't even like say
if something other guy like this guy
really snuck into the whole thing so
that was really cool that was yeah I
love meeting people you love and they
just like live up to everything and you
can talk too much because I freaked out
but I'm sure he would everything leaves
like all of a sudden I'm just an idiot
the same thing happened I really who
have you met that you did you freak out
I like bear hugged Steven Spielberg like
I was sweating bricks and there's like I
love him so much and then I realized I
was squeezing him to pee same thing with
Oprah I mean just you know you just
can't control yourself yeah times you
know I know I wouldn't be able to it's a
huge compliment though because if people
are that affected by you that you must
be doing something really awesome
until it's happening to you and you
don't know what's happening I think it's
so sweet cuz I freaked out over people
like that so I'm always like no I
totally get it
well yeah I freaked out too I freaked
out but so for those people who aren't
familiar like with Icke what is your
actual job like what do you do every day
sure okay cuz I want it cuz you get like
billions of views yeah so I make videos
and my friends basically the best way
describe is somebody who doesn't know is
um it's just trying to have trying to
find new ways to have fun with my
friends every day I guess that's kind of
like this cheesy way to say yeah
and that's pretty much it so we just
record our lives um greatest job it
genuinely like I'm not just saying this
whale is Studio City right up the hill
I'm gonna come in be in a minute
[Applause]
and we're ready no but yeah that's about
it we're just like always I don't know I
don't know every day is completely new
so what's like your most memorable video
that you've ever been a part of my most
memorable well I did the one I get the
most when I see people is I have a
friend and we were just joking around
and he tells me he's like you'll never
find love you'll never find someone to
marry you like as a joke so then the
next day I flew I flew to Boston and
without him knowing and I proposed to
his mother and then it was great so I
proposed his mom and then I flew her to
Vegas to get married and that girl you
got married 100% real
I was I was nervous because at first
like I went to like you have to go to
like this courthouse to get the papers
and I was like and I was like maybe I
shouldn't do this because this is like
pretty serious but then I also like I
also didn't want to fake it so getting
married is so easy it took getting
married is a little more jungle so so
yeah so we got married and then we flew
to Hawaii for our honeymoon and we did
this in we did this in three four days
without him knowing where I was so we
went to the honeymoon she stayed
first of all she's funny she's his mom
he's so great at first she was like she
was confused but then I was like I want
to be Jason's stepdad all for it
yeah and then and then four days later
we flew back and and we went back into
the car we were before and I showed him
the documents all look like courthouse
documents that I'm officially his new
stepdad and that was that was like one
of my favorite moments he loved it too
he was glad his mom was in town because
I brought her from Hawaii because I want
to see it it's recommend everybody
marries the best friend's mom yeah he
took it very well that's the best part
ICU is such a good sport about it that's
so awesome
no but I did hear that you have a
Nickelodeon show right I do yeah what's
it about okay so it's America's most
musical family there it's oh yeah it's a
music competition show it's the best and
they're all families all families
everybody's related in some type of way
there's 30 of them they're already all
extremely extremely talented families so
everybody's just has like killer talent
and we're we're kind of close to the
finals now so we're nearing down to the
to the final person winner gets $250,000
in a recording contract
every family is like it's it's insane
how talented they are it's cool what a
great concept it is yeah I'm surprised
no one's done it yeah me too honestly
yeah all right I'm gonna watch that all
right subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going